oh hello my precious is and welcome to
the monitor obviously because I called
you that you know it's Hobbit week so
let's jump right in and talk about what
Peter Jackson hath wrought these last
few years filming in New Zealand as we
know now he is turning the prelude to
the Lord of the Rings trilogy into not
to movies as originally planned but
three which means that one book is
becoming about eight hours of movie
which might sound like too much but then
you look at a movie like Hunger Games it
tried to digest an entire book and
didn't exactly do it all that well
that's a discussion for another time The
Hobbit if you have not read the book is
the prelude to the Lord of the Rings
trilogy and in event that happened well
before fellowship the Rings the first
book in the trilogy now you know Frodo
Baggins the hero the lord of the rings
trilogy but if you have not read the
book the hobbit then you don't know
Bilbo his uncle who is a hobbit living
in Bag End and is notified by a somewhat
younger Gandalf the Grey that Bilbo is
to go on an adventure with all these
doors to defeat a dragon and restore the
dwarves place under the mountain there
the Misty Mountains which if you are led
zeppelin fanuel familiar with there are
the mines of moria and there are lots of
other things including a guy you may
know named Gollum played by the
inestimable Andy Serkis at any rate the
movie is film partially in 48 frames a
second which is a big bump up from the
industry standard and thus it takes on a
hyper crisp aspect that people seem to
be divided about some people think it's
a disorienting and gives you a bit of a
remove from the movie some people say no
no this heralds a an entire new
technological vanguard of filmmaking i
am not going to judge this for you you
are going to judge this for yourself
when you go see The Hobbit because it's
out this weekend now let's talk about
music you miss outcast I miss outcast
everyone this is outcast best hip-hop
duo of all time no disrespect to nice
and smooth now until andre 3000 and big
boy get back together to do a real album
together not talking about
idlewild soundtrack we have big boy who
is thankfully putting out solo records
and his second official solo album is
out this week it is called vicious lies
and dangerous rumors and the Atlanta
rapper has brought a veritable who's who
of both rap and indie rock to the table
is a few songs with little dragon
there's a few songs with phantogram he's
got guest verses from the usual suspects
TI Ludacris what's his face b.o.b now
it's kind of a glorious mess and and
know that this is not the tightest album
ever made but know also that I love when
people take risks and this is the kind
of album that just would not have
existed before Outkast came around and
you know love goes to big boy for saying
you know what I listen to all this and I
want to work with all the musicians and
there are low points for sure but there
are some really glittering high points
some of the work with phantogram and
little dragon working way better than I
ever would expect it that is vicious
lies and dangerous rumors it is out this
week from big boy take a listen now
let's talk about my other favorite thing
which is comics okay so last week I
spoke a little bit about a new image
comic title called blackacre and I don't
mean to keep going back to the same well
but there is something out this week on
image that I think you should probably
know about the book is called change and
it was written by a young comic writer
named Alice al es I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right Alice caught now
how Scott is all of 26 years old but
over the summer he put out a graphic
novel called wild children that was
really ambitious and astonishing and
change is a miniseries with a different
artist an artist named Morgan Chesky but
al Scott is really experimental beyond
his years this is the story or at least
the beginnings of a story that involve a
rapper named w-2 who is trying to
commission a screenplay for kind of a
biopic of his life and kind of a weird
lovecraftian horror story a screenwriter
named sonja and her agent and a couple
of unnamed shady characters in a van
outside and an astronaut who was on his
way back from a manned mission to Europa
and there is just this crazy sense of
foreboding that runs under the entire
thing there's some really astonishing
artwork in here there's some really
stonking writing in here from the first
page I kind of had this feeling of I
don't know exactly what's going on but I
really like how we're getting to it I
like the dread that suffuses the entire
thing it is called change it starts this
week it is on newstands in comic book
shops online give that a shot okay that
is it for the monitor this week we will
be back next week and then we've got
some holiday goodies plan you can always
email us at this here address below my
fingers but until we see you next week
inspirational catchphrase here